people during this waiting period of 18
months student loan they were getting
money back now that they're going to
have to pay again like they're gonna
have to pay back it's like correct
student loan companies were saying hey
we'll refund you now we'll refund you
here's your 10 grand back we're going to
reinstate your loan balance and good
luck with the government for giving this
that's a punch in the guts now those
people like it's just like it's all of
that stuff you guys so it's so entangled
and as we sit on this side of the desk
trying to help give hope and empowerment
to people when we see this this
narrative play and again regardless of
party like Republicans do this
Democratic it's we see this stuff and
it's so and it's so hard because we also
know as we sit on the side desk that we
have people that stand on the debt free
the debt free stage that do debt-free
screens they've worked hard they've
sacrificed and they've done it so we
know that you can do this and so the
fact that we're not going to be talking
about this anymore in that sense of like
this waiting game I'm gonna wait and see
it no now you can put action to your
life